hello everyone I'm Alana welcome to my
channel and today we are doing another
gaming q a i do these once a month
around the 15th or if you leave
questions in the comments below I will
pull them into next months but this is
gaming specific if you want to ask
anything non-gaming related I do that on
my second Channel I'll leave a link to
that in the description below as well
also sorry about the setup I'm in
Australia it is
unbelievably sweaty it's so hot because
it's a mix of just like hot weather and
um humidity because it keeps raining so
and I also just um my webcam is really
good but it actually needs a power
outlet and I didn't bring enough us to
Au converters so
built-in webcam doing its best sorry
just about everything just in general
first question from Sammy J Smith said
hey Alana just wondering we could get
your general reactions to the game
awards by the way congrats on all the
awards
thank you yeah so I went to the game
awards in person as I do every year it
was a really good show this year I
thought actually
um I really enjoyed it there were some
surprises uh apparently a lot of people
knew about armored Core I did not
definitely a thing that's happened since
I stopped working in media many years
ago now is that I am not up to date with
news at all I tend to be more up to date
with like Game Dev Twitter and what game
devs are talking about but not like
General game Community News so
apparently Ahmed Cole was rumored for a
really long time I had no idea
if you don't already know this I [ __ ]
love ahmedical some of you might have
seen when I went on kind of funny they
asked me a question about Ahmed cool
and I guess I was the only person they'd
ever asked that same one question to
who'd ever played it and I was very
confused because they yelled at me and I
was like what what's happening I don't
understand what's happening because I
didn't know the context of most people
being like I never played on would call
I love almond cool big fan and at first
when that trailer started I was like
this is so pretty and then from soft
came up and I was like oh my God is this
armored Core like the whole trailer my
mouth was like
I did not know
um lost my mind very excited about that
one always happy to have anything and
everything from supergiant so that was
awesome
um nice to see Judas finally get
revealed Ken Levine's game and of course
um for the awards yeah God of War one
six Awards which is amazing
um very cool to be a part of at all even
if you know as I've repeatedly said I
barely did anything and feel no
ownership whatsoever but it's slowly
becoming more and more clear to me that
everybody at Studio says that everyone's
like I didn't do anything
um but no really I didn't do anything
but especially very proud of the
accessibility award for God of War
Ragnarok and proud to
even know the people on that team such
an incredible feat and such incredible
people and I just um a really wonderful
thing to have anything to do with
whatsoever and it's more just continuous
Pride to be among those people yeah very
it was a really wonderful night uh I
think I had said this in numerous videos
beforehand but of course eldering was
going to win game of the year absolutely
no doubt there
um so I'm just happy God of War won
anything when it is it doesn't even
matter Awards who cares I'm just happy
that we had a good night it wasn't as
long as normal
it felt like some of the reveals were
awesome
um I've seen some people come in about
like they were surprised that xBox
wasn't there but I didn't really mean
anything to me they had a showing where
they laid out everything that was coming
out in the next 12 months and so I think
I never expected an Xbox Presence at the
game awards but yeah I don't know I
thought it was a really good show I
thought it was it was faster it was fun
it was really nice to be there in person
this year usually it feels way too long
and I didn't feel that way this time but
again maybe that's just because of the
context of Ragnarok meant that each
award was a bit more significant I still
really hate the parts where they just
like like Ludwig was sitting in my row
maybe like three people down for me
and when Jeff goes content creator of
the Year Ludwick and he's just sitting
there there's no stage thing for it I
just it almost feels like you should
just cut them like
there's something really awkward about
rushing through Awards especially for
people who are in the room I don't know
I do really want to play the full spoken
demo because I've had so much to say
about that game
so I'm hoping to do that before the end
of the week and I also the next episode
of um video game writing 101
is about high on life with Justin
Roiland and Alec Robbins uh who were
wonderful to talk to so that will be up
by the end of the week as well oh and
one last thing I was also blown away by
that Diablo trailer I thought that
Diablo trailer was so good poor did all
all the atmosphere skull robot asked two
quick questions is there a game where
everyone on play watch listen has been a
part of it um
oh
no but close I mean I think everyone on
playwatch listen has been a part of a
different Biffle game obviously Mike is
a part of every people game
but I worked on solitec conspiracy Troy
worked on John Wick X and Austin worked
on John Wick hacks which is actually uh
how playwatchlisten started Mike asked
me to moderate the John Wick hex panel
at San Diego sorry New York Comic-Con
because I had known Mike for years I
don't know through the industry whatever
I am you know also new Austin and Troy
so we all knew each other just vaguely I
was probably closest to Troy at the time
and then we did that panel and I was
like
hey we had very good chemistry we were
laughing on stage everyone's very
enthusiastic and I thought that the
different vocations that we all come
from uh offer interesting perspectives
so I was like can we do this as a thing
like a regular thing and I think I said
it on that night after the panel um but
I don't I don't think I've overlapped I
don't think Solitaire conspiracy was
Austin or Troy so no we have not worked
on a game together but we've all worked
on different Bissell games and we've all
worked together in different capacities
I've also worked with cloak who Troy
works with
I helped Mike with his audiobook
um or audio play thing it's yeah but
nothing completely together the
follow-up question was do you ever think
there would be a possibility that there
would be a game that is made by Mike
written by yourself scored by using a
voice by Troy and the answer is no
if you want to support the patreon um I
am intending to make more of the player
watchlist and animated shorts the next
one is currently being worked on it was
supposed to be made months and months
and months ago but the animator was just
super busy so we're catching up on that
now but the reason that we won't make a
game together
um and we have floated the idea is
because Mike doesn't want to have to
code the whole thing
which I respect he was like yeah but
then I have to make the game
people like well yeah that's fair
so um I'm making video games pretty
difficult turns out but we still have
more creative ideas for things that we
want to do uh in a bunch of capacities
so I do think that there will be more
playwatch listen outside of just the
podcast making a video game probably not
it is time to talk about keeps before I
agree to partnering with them I asked a
whole bunch of friends both who have
used keeps and have thought about using
keeps and everyone pretty much
unanimously had very positive things to
say because we don't often talk about
realistic options for helping men with
their insecurities of course if you are
bold or Bolding or love to you you don't
need to feel insecure about it but if
you are there is something that you can
do two out of three guys will experience
hair loss by the time they're 35 and
keeps office clinically proven research
back treatments to help stop hair loss
and improve hair growth with keeps you
can get quality expert care without ever
visiting a doctor's office or Pharmacy
all keeps treatment plans are
recommended by a licensed medical
provider and delivered straight to your
door at about half the cost of a
traditional Pharmacy cubes has a network
of Expert Medical providers prescribers
and Care Specialists to support you in
making your here goes a reality each
treatment plan comes with a full year of
unlimited messaging so you can connect
with your medical provider about
anything anytime whether you're looking
to prevent hair loss stimulate hair
growth or just take better care of the
hay you have keeps has you covered in
addition to clinically proven treatments
keeps has an award-winning all-natural
thickening shampoo and conditioner
system Keith's Physicians will help you
select the right products and treatments
for your specific condition and hair
goals easily subscribe to keeps and get
refill reminders so you'll never run low
on the products you need to take care of
your hair hair loss stops with keeps to
get 50 off your first order go to
keeps.com Alana Pierce or click the link
in the description that's ke ps.com
Alana Pierce Joey last name said would
you consider doing promo work in the
marketing department once you're working
writing for release is complete
uh no
I don't work in marketing
um marketing is the thing that I did
study at University for one semester as
part of my degree
but uh it doesn't really work that way
those skills aren't that transferable
I'm not a a marketing person I don't
have any experience in marketing it's
not my
um area of study or expertise I have
been a writer for a decade and that is
the thing that I care about and want to
do so it's not even like that no I
wouldn't a I have no interest in
marketing sounds boring as [ __ ] when I
left Rooster Teeth there are a lot of
people who like oh I bet she's going to
be a community manager somewhere with
what community management experience of
course there was going to be a writer
that's that's what all my experiences in
um and I don't think that marketing or
Community Management are that easy those
are jobs that require
skill sets and and things I don't have
things I haven't done it would be very
weird to take that job away from anybody
and also I just don't have any interest
in it I don't I'm good Remo 847 asked
Alana just wondering if you have any
evolved Impressions on Pokemon scarlet
and violet after you've played a few
more hours so I still feel the same way
about scarlet and violet as I did in the
beginning which is
um so I'm playing Violet for the record
so let's just say violet I really enjoy
it I think it's a very fun game and
there are many things about it that I
find to be like extremely Pleasant like
just things that are really fun and
beautiful and
cute and quirky even the writing very
simple I would never want to write on a
Pokemon game myself but I found the
writing to be just fun and cute and
quirky so I really like the game part
two of that is while I really like the
game
I also think it is
pretty much inexcusable that it runs as
poorly as it does and looks as bad as it
does and even that's conflicting because
I think the art design the intent is
stunning you can see what they tried to
do with this beautiful city that I think
is beautifully laid out
even the environments are laid out in in
ways that would be nice if they didn't
look like us but they do and the reason
it's inexcusable
where like usually that's something
that's just so incredibly entitled
um is making games is very hard
is because Pokemon is still the highest
grossing franchise of all time and yes
most of that money comes from merch not
from video games
but still so I simultaneously think it's
very fun
and I enjoy playing it and I'm having a
good time playing it and I also think
that it is so poor in terms of
performance though I will say not as bad
as the internet led me to believe I've
not had anything game breaking it's not
unplayable which is what people were
saying ahead of when I played it it's
just jarringly ugly it's just hideous
in the strangest way because again the
settings so like Pleasant and nice it's
such a bummer and it's also a tough one
because the games won't get better if we
don't stop buying them and I don't stop
buying them
I recognize that the only way to really
prove to anybody that game freak
um has to make better games is if the
game stop being purchased and yet I
don't have that in me I'm part of the
problem hey at least I don't do
pre-orders or season passes or micro
transactions okay I do keep buying
Pokemon games and I think
there are probably a multitude of
problems no Dev wants to make a bad game
I will push back a thousand times over
on the premise that it's lazy devs that
are the problem that's nonsense nobody
wants to make a bad game games are hard
to make and I know that like to a lot of
people we're good at the disability
thing but it does they're so much harder
than you think and I only say that or
reiterate that so often no one's telling
you that the job is any harder than any
blue collar job or whatever right no
one's telling you that it's harder than
being a truck driver it's not what games
are hard to make means
is that there are a million things that
you the audience might go this is dumb
why did they do this and there is a very
good reason why they didn't do it that
you would only understand if you're in
the room that a million people have
thought of that that anyone who ends up
working in game development has
experienced and knowledgeable
and certainly not lazy or you would just
get fired especially at a place like
game freak but that there are just
so many complications that prevent
things from happening and my guess with
game freak is that it is a lack of staff
and not enough time the switch Hardware
is a contributor it's just not the
biggest contributor because obviously
you have something like Xenoblade which
looks beautiful breath of the wild looks
better than Pokemon though also still
had plenty of frame rate drops and is
still you know pretty lacking compared
to other consoles and PC of course
switch is part of the problem but it is
not the problem I would think the
problem
is money and time and
I don't know if it's a publisher
situation where they need to be offered
more money in time it probably is and it
would be really nice and I mean I think
there was an article that came out um I
haven't done uh good gaming news for two
weeks because I haven't had time because
the game wants to travel whatever but I
believe they did address it which
normally they just don't even do that so
we will take it being addressed just
yeah I really like the game I think it's
really fun
I also think it looks like trash and
that that it is inexcusable it does need
to be spoken about Devastator what is
your most anticipated game for 2023
that's a tough one Diablo 4 is very high
up there obviously
um Zelda tears of the Fallen Kingdom is
that what it's called
I anticipate the game but clearly not
well enough to remember the exact title
there are some words after Zelda uh it's
still breath of the wild two in my head
I would say those are the main two right
now at least we tried gaming settle and
I have two questions for you one what
would be your personal game of the year
for 2022
my game of the year was actually sifu
I'm obviously removing god of war from
that entirely because I can't even look
at it that way
um and I do love Elder ring and think it
deserved game of the year like if I like
take a step back from everything like
take a step back from even my own sort
of opinion eldering is incredible what
it did is incredible the way it like
grabbed everybody can't be understated
it's huge but I just loved sifu I adored
it just the like repeatedly going
through those extremely stylish levels
with the even the limited amount of
character that they had I just thought
was so fun and really like
the puzzle aspect of it of getting to
know the levels and how to approach
every fight to get through every level
without dying I just yeah I loved it
loved it so seafood's my game of the
year this year for personal reasons but
again I always have two I always say
that I have two games every year and
it's the one that I think deserves the
award and then the one that I personally
would award it to and it's Elder ring
deserves the award I would personally
give it to sifu again I'm completely
removing God of War Ragnarok even from
my brain I've been playing that game for
coming on three years now it doesn't
work in my brain to equate it to any
awards whatsoever just it just can't it
doesn't exist in your brain in the same
way when you work on something and the
second question was do you have any
plans in the future work with kind of
funny games daily on the stream uh
spoiler cast Etc I'm happy to go hang
out we're kind of funny anytime they ask
I would have gone to the studio launch
but I was overseas somebody's taking the
trash out
um yeah always down let them know you
want me on stuff and I always say yes I
love all of them very much so absolutely
always down as I continue to work with
fun house on Deadly Premonition they're
all just wonderful people always happy
to
and I think we've covered most of the
questions oh this is an easy one that I
did actually answer
dyslexia potatoes six for one so sorry
if this has been asked before but what
is your main platform for gaming
uh just curious what you typically play
third-party games I would say it depends
on what's available and when but
majority of the time if I have an option
I will pick PC
uh that is it from me today everybody
thank you for watching I'm very sweaty
I'm about to hang out with my Grandma so
I'm gonna go do that and yeah leave
questions about video games below or you
can leave them on my personal Channel
really wherever is fine for the next IRL
q a which I'll probably have in a couple
of weeks uh before the end of the year
as well
see you guys next time